the heading is dot product in 3d now as
promised
a lot of the things that we've been
covering so far in extension two vectors
have been things that you knew from
extension one vectors in 2d
and then we've gone ahead and we've
added another dimension to them right
and uh that's going to be today's lesson
in some measure but i want to push on
that
this is one of those wonderful places
where you see you gain this qualitative
difference
when you move into three dimensions with
something like the dot product
that just isn't there in two dimensions
so we'll get to that
um slight spoilers uh for what's coming
ahead
before we get there though as i've just
established right
you can't understand the dot product in
3d well unless you know what's going on
with the dot product in
2d and i know for a small subsection of
you
this will look familiar but for several
of you it will not so i'm just going to
give you my
like a 90 second version of how i think
about
the dot product and there's so many
different ways that you can think about
this whichever way works for you
um i think you need to have some kind of
metaphor in your head
whether it's you know playing a video
game or holding a bucket to rain
or thinking about a windy day on the
beach otherwise
you're just crunching numbers right and
we do not want you to be people who are
we don't want you to be
computers you know computers used to be
people like that was their job because
we didn't have
objects that could do the calculations
that we needed to rely on human beings
who could compute things right we want
to go past the computation and think
about what does it mean
so imagine yourself on the beach trying
to walk toward
the water and importantly it doesn't
matter where in the water you land
you're just trying to
get to you're just trying to get wet
right so you're just trying to get out
there okay
now if it's a windy day if it's a windy
day
which it often is at the beach right
then the question that the dot product
answers is
how much is the wind swelling around you
how much is it helping you
towards the water or how much is it
hindering you
away from your goal away from the water
right now clearly it depends on two
things
and you can see why this relates to
vectors right
how much the wind is helping or
hindering you depends on which way is
the wind blowing
what's its direction and how much force
is the wind applying i guess what is its
magnitude right
so in the caseware and this is usually
the case right if the water's
coming sorry the wind is coming out from
the ocean and blowing at you
okay then it's opposing you directly
right if you're coming at an angle
though right it's not going to be
opposing you
as much as if it were like if you're
directly walking into the wind if you've
ever had that experience before
right so in these cases what is the dot
product going to tell you well number
one
it's opposing you so it's going to be
negative when you have this kind of
opposing direction of the vectors and if
they're opposing directly that's the
most negative it can get
if you're sort of like a little bit
negative like this indirect situation
over here
then your dot product is going to be
lesser because the
effect on you the amount it's hindering
you from getting to the water
is lesser maybe it'll blow you to a
slightly different point in the water
than you intended but you'll still get
to the water
right now if you think about if the wind
is just running along the beach
it's going to have an impact on you but
it's not going to
slow you down nor is it going to speed
you up in terms of getting to the water
does that make sense it's just going to
blow you kind of sideways
right you'll still get there if you're
still walking at the same pace and
that's why when we say the dot product
of two vectors that are what's that word
again
now in 2d we can say perpendicular right
but now in three dimensions we would
more use the word
orthogonal right so if you've got two
orthogonal vectors like you heading
towards the water
and then the wind at right angles to you
then that gives your dot product equal
to
zero right so they're not really acting
on each other at all in terms of trying
to get to
the water uh we know what happens if one
of the vectors that you're thinking
about
is a zero vector then just by
computation like just doing it
in component form right think about
multiplying the zeros
you get a dot product of zero as well
because again no impact if there's no
wind
right and then you've got these other
situations where the wind is helping you
and obviously the more wind there is the
higher that magnitude
the more it helps you out right so this
is kind of our summary
right positive means we're acting in the
same direction
negative means we're acting in opposing
directions to some degree
zero means there's no impact and the
bigger the actual size because it's a
scalar product that's the other name
right
so we're going to get a number at the
end bigger the magnitude is
the bigger the effect uh in either
direction make sense
okay so now let's think about let's try
and come back to this idea of
what does that actually mean for the
calculation of this thing if we have
pico pins
if we have two vectors
a and b and we compute the dot product
we had
two different ways to work out what this
thing was
and we did it in two dimensions firstly
by saying
component form and then hopefully you
might remember we used some trigonometry
to get to an alternative definition now
what i'm going to try and do is go
today number one in 3d number two in the
opposite
direction so based on this idea here of
trying to think about
it's to do with magnitude and it's to do
with like how do the angles of these two
vectors relate
weirdly i'm going to write down i'm
going to try and visually justify it for
you right
weirdly even in three dimensions our dot
product
for these two things actually has
the exact same
definition as it does in two dimensions
you remember this formula right or maybe
you had using v's instead of
a's and b's same diff right you need to
know what the magnitude
of the two vectors is and then you need
to consider the angle
between them now if you're like me the
first time you see this you're like
how can this be this seems weird to me
that the dot product in 3d
looks identical to the dot product in 2d
we're used to it becoming
more complicated right and i want to try
and justify for you why
that is not the case so
let me see if i can get an angle let's
go well actually first i'll face it in a
more
sensible direction imagine this as
well when we think about our x y z
coordinate
space right i want you to imagine these
as i'm going to put it at an angle so
you can see it a little bit better
right we normally have the x axis coming
out towards you along the ground
we've got the y axis coming off in this
direction usually to your
right okay and by the way please stand
up if it's going to help you because i
know
are sort of tall people in the way you
got x y
laid flat and then you got z coming up
into the you know
height up and down right so far so good
now what i want to try and convince you
of using this and you can also do it
algebraically but i find this much more
convincing
what i want to convince you of is that
when you have two vectors
in 3d you can more or less for the
purpose of the dot product
consider them in 2d right here's where
i'm going to do it
imagine imagine you've got two vectors
that you're comparing together now for
the sake of simplicity and because of
the fact that i only have two hands
let's just treat the uh positive part of
the x-axis that's coming out at you
let's just treat that as one of our two
vectors okay
and then the other vector is going to be
this black one right now
imagine i'm going to do this for
simplicity sake first right imagine if i
make it
well just the z-axis right you see that
now literally by definition you can see
these pieces of wood here that help you
out
you can obviously see that that first
vector
and my second vector they clearly share
a plane
does that make sense i mean in this case
it's the x z
plane so the fancy word for this and i
should write this down and so should you
the fancy word for this is that they are
co-planar
co-planar do you remember when we talked
about points being co-linear
co-linear means points on the same line
coplanar means you've got two vectors
and they're on the same
plane no big deal okay so if i had a
simple situation like this
x-axis z-axis of course they share a
plane
once you've written that down look up
again and have a look at what i'm about
to do this black vector
right obviously i can rotate it around
along the xz plane right and it's still
on the same
2d space i can do this kind of rotation
to it and it stays on the same plane
agreed so i haven't like even though i
have this degree of freedom
i'm still going to be coplanar okay but
now imagine what happens if i try and
come off the
x z plane okay so i'm going to start
again with this
simple situation z-axis now let's like
put it over here
right so it's coming out sort of
diagonal into the first octane it's what
we called it before because
x and y and z are positive okay
can you see can you yet visualize i'm
going to help you in a second don't
worry
but can you visualize the plane
that is shared by the x-axis and my
second
vector can you visualize it right now
what i would do what i think is the
easiest way to think about it is
start from the x-z plane that we were on
before right and then think about what
would happen if
like how far do you have to rotate this
xz plane
and in which direction do you have to
rotate it to get to my second vector
and i don't have to do very much here i
literally just have to
let it go right can you see my new red
plane
clearly shares uh the x
z that first vector right it's still
passing through there right it's like
cutting through
and it's also now sitting on top of my
second vector is that all right and i
can literally put that second vector
wherever i like i can obviously come
around
to this side and i can play exactly the
same trick whichever octant you're in
it's what we call a symmetric operation
so no matter which weird angle i rotate
on
i've got a plane that my second vector
is sitting on
and also that original vector which was
the x-axis
it's also sitting on does that make
sense so
what's my point even in three dimensions
if you think about the magnitude of each
of those that has nothing to do with
being three-dimensional
but if you think about the angle between
them all you need is
that one extra weirdo oblique plane
just consider that as your like what
you're drawing
right and there's going to be a normal
two-dimensional angle
between your three-dimensional vectors
does that make sense
okay so this is why our initial
definition for the dot protein in 3d
is identical to the one in 2d